So, a few days ago, I cheerfully shipped to my boyfriend and asked him ...
-Hey babe, can you see something different?
- Uhhhh ...
is
the
your...
Hua! Dancing vagina
-Mhyhy, hahaha ... [vicious laughter]
And it was so much fun! I mean it wasn't fun, but it was a little fun
because every time I ask:
- Can you see something different?
It is as if my partner hears:
“What always runs but never goes?
often murmur but never speak?
have a bed but never sleep?
have a mouth but never eat?
Um ...
[Whispers]
Haa ...
It's a river!
OK.
"We hurt without moving. We poison without touching.
We keep truth and lies. We cannot be judged on size.
What are we?
Aaaaa ...
Oh god, think, think, think ...
Word! It's words!
"Can you see something different?"
Um ...
Oh.
Is it...
[Breathes heavily]
...your...
...hair?
WRONG!
AND NOW YOU MUST PAY WITH YOUR LIFE!
But I can't let everybody, you know?
if i do something i will know if you notice it.
And it's like I'm trying to trick you.
But I'm trying to test you.
[dynamic music, clock ticking]
[Alarm clock]
NOTHING! NOTHING IS CHANGED!
Wait! You fooled me!
What has eyes but can't see?
NOOOOOOO!
An adult man but a baby
Don't do this!
You don't know me at all ...
Oh no, babe! No!
But I don't know, maybe this is a really heteronormative thing, right?
If I was gay would I be able to get away with this?
-Hey babe, can you see something different?
-You've changed your hair parting to the middle, changed your glasses from Holcomb to Riple, dyed your brows, really made a good eyeliner.
And you are now making a more conscious attempt to be fashion conscious.
And you're doing great!
- Oh my God! Baaaaabe!
I love you.
- Love you too!
Or is it stereotypical of me?
I do not know.
>>> I'd like to be more LGBT + inclusive. But that's not what I know so I can't necessarily speak on their behalf
so understand that scene was a straightforward reflection of a heterosexual girl, of what is of course
a more complex and three-dimensional gay relationship, in the context of this video's exploration of "can you see something different" <<<
disclaimer gone
But what about you guys? Maybe you ask your partner that question, and that's not an important thing.
And they don't react like that at all.
- Can you see something different?
- No, what did you do?
- Oh, I've made my eyebrows.
- Oh, cool. Want to watch TV?
Maybe instead of fear of not getting it right, they are sad not to be able to see it sooner?
Oh my God! What do you say! Of course, you've changed your hair!
I should have seen it right away. What does it mean?
Does that mean we're not in love anymore? But I thought you were the love of my life.
I have failed as a human being.
Personally, I discover everything.
- EVERYTHING -
- Hey babe, do you see anything different?
- Yeah, you're a giant cat now.
- Uh. Can't get anything past you.
Oh man ...
I'm Anna Akana.
Stay ... right here for a sponsored message that I wrote in an enigma and it was really hard, but I did.
And maybe I fell into a pool afterwards, who knows?
Only you know if you stay.
Or you roll earlier
I can't control, can't control you.
Who sponsored today's episode?
and offers news, comedy and audio books ...?
When your eyes and hands are full but want to
listening and learning in traffic or doing laundry.
Who can explore the wisdom of the wise man anywhere?
And other great collections of books ... if you dare.
Which offer their service FREE for 30 days. So you can try their Audible roads ...
Audible.com/Anna
It's Audible.com/Anna
The best way to fight a wizard is to drown them in knowledge.
Where's my water bottle?
Oh, it's here.